[Musik]
einen wunderschönen abend zu viertel
nach acht dem talk der schlagzeilen
macht wir sprechen die themen an die
deutschland heute wirklich bewegen und
vor allem die themen die unsere gäste
hier bewegen und wir haben besondere
gäste auch heute abend zu recht denn
mario brandenburg fdp
bundestagsabgeordneter und
technologiepolitische sprecher béla anda
kommunikationsexperte kommunikations
genie kann man sagen und ehemaliger
regierungssprecher zu meiner linken die
weltbekannte mittlerweile kann man sagen
der schink bestseller-autorin und uli
jorges star -kolumnist zu beginn darf
ich anfangen mit einem thema das mich
bewegt hat und zwar geht es da um
alexander lukaschenko und was der mit
den flüchtlingen macht verändert hat ja
da gab es eine fast revolution in minsk
ich hab von dort damals berichtet große
hoffnung dass lukaschenko stürzen würde
dann hat putin ihm geholfen und nichts
passierte und was macht lukas schenkel
jetzt er provoziert die europäische
union lässt flüchtlinge einfliegen nach
minze aus ganz vielen verschiedenen
ländern auf der welt und schickt die
dann nach polen heute hat horst seehofer
gesagt es brauche dringend
grenzkontrollen heiko maas hat in
brüssel gesagt es brauche auch
flugverbote richtung weißrussland was
mich wirklich wütend macht ist dass uns
lukaschenko so egal geworden ist der
letzte diktator in europa und uns
interessiert nicht wirklich nur jetzt wo
die flüchtlinge vor unserer grenze
stehen da ist das thema plötzlich wieder
da ich finde wir müssen viel härter viel
schärfer mit viel größeren sanktionen
gegen lukaschenko vor ja da stellen sich
aber zwei fragen anschließend erstens
wer tut das europas moment zu
handlungsunfähig wie es lange zeit nicht
mehr war auf der einen seite löst sich
polen von europäischen union es gibt
einen ständigen konflikt ob polen
überhaupt noch dabei sein will oder
rausgehen will mir ja auch die
europäische grenzschutzagentur
und zum anderen ist deutschland gelähmt
weil die regierung die wir haben schon
nicht mehr richtig reagiert also der
lukaschenko hat klar erkannt dass an die
weichteile europas gehen kann das tut
damit großer und es passiert nichts zum
anderen glaube ich es ist ja sind hier
schon einige sanktionen verhängt worden
gegen weißrussland alle wege nach minsk
führen über moskau also man muss
anfangen mit moskau zu reden russland
ist der entscheidende faktor dabei und
ohne russen würde sich lukaschenko das
nicht getrauen also der hat die
rückendeckung von putin
auch putin hat einiges zu gewinnen wenn
er einen deal machen kann mit europa und
man muss mit putin räten und lukas
schinko aufzuhalten überlänge
lukaschenko geredet und ich muss ja auch
reden über
brüssel du hast gesagt aber muss auch
reden war pohl weil die polnische
regierung nutzt diese gelegenheit nicht
wie schamlos aus frontex darf nicht
dahin oder unsere grenz- treffen dürfen
nicht hin die un beobachter werden nur
vereinzelt hin gelassen und was wollen
die polen mache ich sagen wir bauen eine
mauer jetzt bild detmold wie deutschland
york rangers tot erfolg das sagen sie
nicht aber es kommt wahrscheinlich als
nächstes also sie wollen eine mauer
bauen ähnlich wie das mit großem beifall
ihr viktor orban gemacht hat in ungarn
und erhoffen sich die gleichen die
gleichen positiven effekte für ihre
komische regierung da die immer weiter
sich von der eu entfernt und nutzt es
auch politisch in dieser haben hier
schaut bei zu die eu die sie nicht ins
land lassen mit den grenztruppen die tut
nix aber wir wir bauen die mauer und wir
helfen euch euch abzuschotten uns
abschotten von denen die da kommen
natürlich muss es burg verbote geben
viele dieser flüge landen inzwischen in
der türkei und fliegen von da aus dann
weiter nach der weisrussin und werden da
entsprechen dann auch natürlich über die
grenze zwischen herbrand was bedeutet
das für deutschland wenn er jetzt immer
mehr flüchtlinge über die grenze kommen
sie sind ja bald dann teilt der
regierung gibt es vielleicht sogar ein
fdp- innenminister dann der sagen wird
stoppt ganz kontrolle ich glaube das
thema ist so relevant um daran ersehen
welche ministerial diskussion anzuhängen
was vollkommen richtig ist wir sehen was
passiert wenn man so kleine lodernde
innereuropäische feuer aus
verschiedensten gründen
diese untätigkeit vielleicht auch an
unvermögen und nicht wollen lodern lässt
und jetzt sind wir halt an einer
situation die absolut unsere
aufmerksamkeit da braucht es vollkommen
richtig dass jetzt auf die kabinetts
tages kommt der noch aktuell amtierenden
regierung ich glaube absolut dass wir
dann mit flugverboten dran müssen heiko
maas ungewöhnlich scharf muss man jetzt
auch mal sagen und das ist absolut im
ton dann richtig was zum glück aber noch
der fall ist wir sprechen hier noch über
zahlen in dem man noch absolut tätig
werden kann aber es muss natürlich
ändern dass sich lukaschenko im prinzip
hier an den kopf von einer schleuser
bewegung setzt und dann denken wir
machen das spiel machen den er dass
jetzt andere staaten sagen wenn ich
tolle idee so setzen wir jetzt andere
staaten unter druck wir holen uns die
flüchtlinge aus libyen aus afghanistan
von wo auch immer und dann stoßen wir
die über die grenze quartal aber ich
frage mich warum bin ich reagieren also
muss doch jetzt schnell ich mir du warst
vor ort ich hatte damals gesagt bei der
einstigen hatte diese videos gepostet
warum passiert da nichts also was könnte
deutschland sein tonfall um das zu
verhindern um die flüchtlinge
zurückzudrängen mainz oder dass sie gar
nicht erst losgehen glaube ich das ist
momentan veolia jürges richtig sagt
finanzielle situation hier darf was
können wir tun also ich glaube in minsk
selbst können wir nur am ende durch
druck gegenüber wladimir putin
tatsächlich etwas tun weil am ende ist
lukas schenkel nur deshalb noch dort
weil putin unterstützt da gab es diese
berühmten bilder wo er dann nach moskau
bitten und betteln dorthin gefahren ist
und das ist ja so ein bisschen muss man
sagen das problem dass unsere
außenpolitik dann nie wirklich scharf
war insbesondere in europa die grünen
tun jetzt ein bisschen so als würden sie
das ändern können wenn denn annalena
baerbock aussenministerin ist das
bezahlt nicht aber einer der großen
konflikte in dieser koalition werden
glaube ich denn die grünen sind jetzt
mal ganz platt gesagt sehr anti russisch
die spd ist nicht die fdp
eigentlich auch nicht kritisch zwar aber
nicht anti russisch und eigentlich
müsste man darüber nachdenken dass man
das verhältnis zu russland aufräumt es
gibt ja immer noch jede menge sanktionen
gegen russland wegen der krim besetzung
aber die grippesaison wird nicht
zurückgenommen also will man das ad
infinitum weiterlaufen lassen halte ich
für falsch man muss irgendwann auch
anfangen aus den sanktionen rauszugehen
die schaden auch der deutsche oder
europäische
schafft also wenn man mit jedem cent
putin weiter aggressive politik betreibe
ja dass wir das eine ist die
voraussetzungen des anderen am ende ist
man zum kreislauf treffen wo man nicht
mehr weiß wo es angefangen hat man muss
nur versuchen glaube ich diesen zirkel
zu durchbrechen und wir sehen ja auch
die kritik an der an der neuen
gaspipeline von russland nach
deutschland führt die wird ja jetzt
immer stiller wo wir sehen wie die
gaspreise steigen und wie die versorgung
knapp wird und wie in england das ist
zwar nicht gas oder benzin aber immerhin
wie energie knapp wird in england wir
müssen mit den russen reden und anfangen
endlich wieder eine tragfähige beziehung
hat aber dennoch ist doch erstaunlich
dass nur dann uns plötzlich außenpolitik
wieder interessiert wenn flüchtlinge
irgendwie an der grenze sind auch
politik ist immer interessenpolitik und
zwar ausschließlich ausschließlich und
jetzt haben wir interessen wir sehen ja
noch einen anderen fall paul wir gucken
nach
weißrussland wir gucken richtung polen
aber es gibt natürlich viele auch
berichterstatter die da hinfahren und
anderen fokus haben als so
beispielsweise die gehen da hin und
sagen es ist ja unglaublich was ihr auch
passiert ist dass flüchtlinge da
zurückgedrängt werden teilweise mit
einsatz von körperlicher gewalt auch die
kommen ja die durchkommen präsentieren
ihre wunden die die nicht durchkommen
präsentieren meistens europäischen
westeuropäischen fernsehteams ihre
wunden die sie dann eben zu stellen oder
zu zeigen und sagen hier sind wir nicht
durchgelassen worden das sind die folgen
davon also wir haben auch eine sehr
aktivistische öffentlichkeit die
kritisieren dass diese zehntausenden gar
nicht hier reinkommen dürfen und da
läuft ja auch irgendwas falsch denn es
handelt sich hierbei zum teil sicherlich
um verfolgte aber eben nicht nur und wir
haben es nicht geschafft trotz unserer
erfahrung 2015 hier zu einer
vernünftigen einwanderungspolitik zu
kommen und zu einer regelung die sagt
das gilt und das ist eben zu viel des
guten herr brandenburg sie damit die
chance dass in der neuen koalition zu
ändern gibt es da eine chance also ich
habe hier mit geschrieben und zwar ist
es ja die anhäufung von mehreren dingen
wir hatten zuerst es nicht tätig seine
außenpolitik daherkommt im prinzip
dieses reaktionäre der nächste punkt war
genau wir haben seit 2005 zehn ja auch
nicht ein königsweg aufgezeigt also
weder haben wir irgendwie der digitale
möglichkeiten vor ort noch haben wir
aufgezeigt wie es funktioniert gibt es
die spur wechseln also für die menschen
die gehen daher bei weitem nicht aus
spaß los das ist grausam was da passiert
und wir haben eben und jetzt wurde auf
polen genannt aber da ja auch
beispielsweise litauen lettland die das
auch nach einem anderen standort tun
also im prinzip ja die aufgabe von uns
und damit meine ich jetzt egal welche
bundesregierung das ist eine aktive
hilfestellung der staaten zu leisten die
das humanitär auch so angehen wie wir
uns das wünschen denn das hängt dann
wieder alles ein bisschen damit zusammen
dass es aktivismus ist und nicht eben
geplant und ich glaube schon dass wenn
man da aktiver rheinberg und den
menschen den legalen weg aufzeigt und
die länder die sich danach unseren
werten ordentlich verhalten dann auch
unterstützt dann gibt es da auch eine
lösung aus der aus der situation ich
habe eben gesagt die zahlen sind sind
furchtbar aber überschaubar für länder
die sich zusammenraufen und da fehlt es
dann eben wieder genau an anfang an tun
auch nicht mehr wenn was man muss sich
erstmal anschauen aus welchen motiven
die flüchtlinge kommen das hängt
natürlich auch davon ab aus welchem land
sie kommen sie kommen aus verschiedenen
ländern unter anderem aus afghanistan
dafür stehen uns am ehesten beim irak
versteht man vielleicht am wenigsten
sind es also junge männer die hier
arbeiten wollen in europa ihr glück
machen wollen oder sind es wirklich
verfolgte die asylrecht in anspruch
nehmen wenn das nicht so ist
das asylrecht das recht auf asyl haben
sondern aus anderen motiven kommen dann
muss man darüber nachdenken dass man die
die grenzen schließt und sie abwerten
erlebt habe und auch sonst veränderungen
also deutschland brauche zuwanderer aber
ganz knapp aber nicht von jedem da muss
man sich dann schon anschauen was können
die welchen beruf haben sie gelernt
können wir die gebrauchen das recht
haben wir das recht hatte ihre ich finde
es immer wenn ich jetzt sagen ich bin es
immer schwierig das ist immerhin so
gruppierungen machen so es kommen junge
männer und die sind eigentlich schon
jeder blöd ich glaube wenn zum beispiel
ein junger mann quotieren spröde was ich
meine allgemein ist dieser ist es in
deutschland so dass immer junge männer
die kommen weil sie ihr wirtschaftliches
glück machen wollen wenn ihr zb junger
man hinkommt der hart arbeitet und
tollen lebensweg hinlegt finde ich es
überhaupt nicht verwerfen sondern auch
ein land der einwanderung sein sollten
ich frage warum jemand
[Musik]